en reparler s'il vous plaît le rap
violent c'est ta doc gynéco là c'est pas
du rap de gonzesses là c'est clair donc
date unique hausse et durable de
conseils de la barrière c'est bien c'est
marrant un premier temps mais la
variation ça c'est du ce et du hardcore
ça ça compte qualifié ouais on n'y a pas
non plus que des titres hardcore à
l'intérieur ça vous êtes un petit peu
imperméable à berne à un peu oui
vient alors le drame effectivement on a
écouté la pas mal de morceaux d'ntm très
très célèbre le drame c'est le split
donc vous êtes séparé la vraie raison
c'est quoi aujourd'hui
il ya partout on entend un peu alors
vous êtes brouillés à un réel
m'embrouiller n'en artistiquement la fin
quatrième album dont on est très content
aujourd'hui resservir un cinquième album
qui serait juste une copie conforme du
quatrième avec quelqu'un quelques années
plus c'est pas super intéressant c'est
plus ça aurait totalement le single
c'est avec toys et s'appelle are you
ready
12 heures on est gros temps dans l'es12
et vous expliquer à le mouvement de tête
à à bernard il a gardé il avait gardé le
mouvement québec
c'est un mouvement comme ça si le folk
et rock le rap c'est comme ça on va
essayer attention on n'en est pas là
regardez bien comment il fait
il faut que j'arrête là packer munis de
ballons c'est bien on va les remercier
super compliqué non bâle roche qui
l'écouté